cependant dans Paris la vie continue ou
plutôt la vie recommence les premiers
jours de la Libération ressemblent tous
à des dimanches qui seraient un peu des
14 juillet
en l'absence de métro les Parisiens
auraient inventé les autobus de fortune
voir ressusciter les vieux omnibus d'un
chevaux
depuis un mois les bicyclettes ont fait
des petits
les agents ont retrouvé leurs gestes
rituels mais nous font plus circuler que
des cyclistes
le vélo stop a remplacé l'auto-stop
les plus ingénieux vont trouver de
nouveaux moyens de se déplacer sans
charbonnier sens l'armée américaine est
prise en charge par les Parisiens